[Applause]
the pandemic
and plastic have gone hand in hand
millions of single-use face masks gowns
and curtains
have been vital to the fight against
covid
but it's created thousands of tons of
waste
one company in cardiff thinks it has the
solution
six nhs hospitals have already taken
delivery of their specialist machines
that convert used ppe into reusable
plastic
we have a number of trusts now using our
machines
and specifically to
take out the plastics and also the face
mask which has become a huge problem in
the current pandemic
you take royal cornwall for instance
they're using 10 000
masks a day instead of being incinerated
or going to landfill
thermal heating is used to melt down the
ppe
we've got around 3 000 faulty single-use
face masks here what happens is they go
inside the machine
at the hospital for around an hour what
comes out is this 20 kilogram block of
plastic
it's being reused already to make things
like tool boxes
and new school chairs the aim to go full
circle on ppe waste
at the start of the pandemic the world
health organization called on
governments and manufacturers to
increase
single-use ppe production by 40 percent
in china output of masks soared to 116
million per
day in february last year around 12
times the usual amount
one study suggests that in the last 12
months 19.2 billion
single-use face masks have been used in
the uk
alone weighing around 55 000 tons
to put that into context the weight of
face masks
used in the uk in the last year is
equivalent to around
37 000 cars a huge amount
but still a tiny proportion of the 220
million tons of waste
the uk produces every year there has
been
an increase in ppe that we're all well
aware about
but um the system the waste management
system
has coped it's very resilient system
we are not talking about huge amount of
volumes of material compared to the
overall amount that we're handling
for the uk as a whole in any given year
there is little sign of ppe
demand falling being able to turn this
covered waste
into something new could be the
long-term solution
damn white is sky news in cardo